Las Vegas's biggest convention starts
tomorrow it's the Consumer Electronics
Show back to pretty much full strength
after years of coronavirus restrictions
but this year CES does still include new
testing requirements starting tomorrow
the Centers for Disease Control is
requiring travelers from China Hong Kong
and Macau to test negative for
Coronavirus before coming here to the
U.S CES is also requiring negative tests
for people arriving from those areas so
that means some people are canceling
their travel plans
when people come in town they always get
this package deal with travel agencies
that they will take them to different
restaurants locally in town and to
different spots and to go shopping to go
eat you know tour buses certainly see
those tour buses a lot but some people
are canceling Las Vegas Convention and
visitors Authority though still expects
a hundred thousand visitors for CES one
of the final numbers though until the
program ends on Sunday Sherry well to
the showroom floor we go more than 3 100
exhibitors will display the latest
gadgets throughout the next four days of
the convention Candace Charles joins us
live from the convention center with a
look at the final preparations and some
fun stuff that's already being previewed
good morning Candace
Good morning Sherry good morning folks
yes lots of folks coming down here
exhibitors for about 150 countries folks
from all over the world I heard about a
third coming from all over the world
really a lot of different countries down
here including folks coming from China
as we have mentioned so there's been a
few restrictions some of that may have
impacted CES which is run by the
consumer technology Association CTA and
I'm joined by Ali freed from CTA thank
you so much for joining us this morning
tell us a little bit about how those
restrictions have impacted the trade
show yeah good morning we are thrilled
to be back in Las Vegas
um like you said it's a global show
people coming from all around the world
anyone coming from China Hong Kong or
Macau they do need to make sure to
present a negative covid test within 48
Hours of arriving on site that was in
effect January 1st through January 4th
today we're following government
mandates just to make sure that everyone
is as healthy and safe as possible at
the show it's a major priority for us as
the world comes together to experience
the greatest and latest technology at
CES this week absolutely so they got
till today to get it done here but they
can get it done elsewhere but today's
last day to get done here as we
mentioned lots to see we talked a little
bit about the autonomous race car that's
here it'll be racing out at the
racetrack on Saturday so that would be
pretty awesome to see lots of different
things including this the dozy Cozy now
I have a purple mattress but I don't
have the purple pillow Ali how would
this help me I know so this is amazing
so digital health is a huge theme that
we're seeing across the show floor and
this dozy cozy air pillow is an AI
activated smart pillow to help you sleep
the most soundly and comfortable that
you can speak in my language I know
right I'm on in the morning right so
there is this wastement you put this on
your waistband and it knows exactly how
you're sleeping are you on your side are
you on your backyard are you on your
stomach and then the pillow
automatically adjusts to your needs so
what does your neck need for support
what does your brain need for support it
has built-in Bluetooth so you can play
your music it also has white noise we
know how important sleep is we all need
it none of us get enough of it and the
dozy Cozy AI smart pillow is I think
what we all need I think so too I'm
gonna get this for you guys John and
Heather John so you can be less grumpy
headless so you can be delightful as you
always are just kidding you guys okay
how much is this really quickly so it
retails about 6 50 right now it is
available uh dozie cozy I think.com is
where you can go but it'll be on the
show for uh Booth 811 at the Las Vegas
Convention Center awesome Ally just
kidding I'm not gonna be buying that for
you guys because it's too expensive
thank you so much Ali for joining us
this morning we appreciate you lots to
see here as I mentioned it all kicks off
tomorrow we got to cover all details on
our website 8newsnow.com for now live
from the convention center on the CES
show floor I'm Kevin Charles 8 news now
it's a thought that counts though
Candice the thought that counts grumpy
John yeah the shot's fired huh I mean
she's not wrong oh man I love that
though and none of us sleep on the ship
so that's cool